-That's a movie star
right there, bud.
You look sharp.
Thanks so much
for coming on the show.
I appreciate it.
-Appreciate you.
Thank you for having me.
-Thanks for coming back.
And, also, now we can say you're
officially a New Yorker.
-Hey!
-That's what I'm t-- Right?
Is this real?
-Yeah, yeah, man.
I've been on the road for about
four years, since January 2017.
-Working?
-Yeah.
Working, working,
which I'm fortunate to
you know, be in that position.
But now I got a place.
I can sit down, you know,
get into a little bit
of normalcy, go for walks.
-Yes! Good. Welcome.
Do you love the city?
-Yeah. The city's beautiful.
I'm glad to be here.
You know, it's always good to be
here during Christmastime.
You know,
I'm back seeing theater.
I'm trying to shop.
I just learned about amazon.com.
You know? I'm serious.
Serious, man.
-You just learned about it?
-Yeah.
Like, you know, I mean,
everybody's kind of been,
you know, telling me about it,
but I'm a guy --
I really don't like change.
You know what I'm saying?
So it took me a long time
to get around to it.
But now it's just like,
you know,
that's my pastime
right now is just --
-Mind -- A whole world --
-Soaps, rugs, face serums,
you know, a brush.
I got a scale.
It's normal things, right?
-But that's -- You don't have to
go out and shop for it.
-Like I'm used to.
You know, like, I'm used to
going out, standing in a line,
and things like that.
They said, "No, man,
you got to get on amazon.com."
And I'm like --
-This is interesting, 'cause
you're here to talk about --
You're not even here for Amazon.
You're here to talk about
"The Matrix."
-Right, but, like, I need to
spread the gospel, right?
Amazon.com.
It will change your life.
-Alright, thank you.
I appreciate that.
I want to say
congrats on starting
your production company.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Tell me about that.
-Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So, it was just announced
a couple days ago,
my production company,
House Eleven10.
is in partnership with Netflix,
so I'll be able to,
you know, produce my own films
and really put my ideas
out into the world.
So I'm very, very
excited about that.
-House Eleven10.
-House Eleven10, yeah.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
It's named after the house
that I grew up in
in Oakland, California, 1110,
in Oakland, California.
-Oh, congrats.
-So, now one of the hats,
apparently, that comes with it
is job man.
You know,
everybody hittin' me up,
you know, thinking that I'm
giving out jobs now.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, now you got
a production company,
they're like, "Hey, hire me.
I'm the perfect person for --"
-Yeah, like,
"I don't know what I do,
I don't know what you do,
but I know
you're giving out jobs."
You know what I'm saying?
-You're like,
"No, I don't have an idea.
I'm not building something yet,
but when I do --"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You got a lot of people
sending you résumés?
-Oh, résumés and bad scripts.
-Yeah, exactly.
Bad scripts, yeah, yeah.
-I know that -- I was reading,
you know, before acting,
you studied architecture
and that you still draw
in your free time.
-Yeah, a little bit, little bit.
-What do you draw?
-It depends.
You know, it depends on
what I'm working on.
Sometimes, I draw my characters.
I try to draw buildings
and things like that
every once in a while
just to keep that muscle going.
Last year, I had
a lot of fun getting on my
Instagram Live with
my fans and supporters
and doing portraits
and things like that.
-Yeah, I saw this. Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So, I have a thing,
but could you --
If I gave you
a marker and a paper,
could you draw a portrait of me?
-Oh, yeah,
no doubt, no doubt, no doubt.
Let's do it.
-Yeah.
-I'll tell you what.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I'll tell you what,
if you got yours --
Yeah, okay.
Okay, yeah, there you go.
You grab
a marker, pen, and paper,
and we'll do it like this.
We'll do 15 seconds.
But this is the rules, right?
We've got to keep eye contact
the entire time.
-Oh, no.
-Yeah.
-I can't look here?
-No, no, no, no.
You can't -- Just let your eye
follow the pen --
I mean, just let your hand
follow your eye.
Here we go.
♪♪
Okay, we got some drawing music.
Okay, here we go.
-You ready, bud?
-Yeah, okay, here we go. Boom.
Uh-huh.
-Uh-huh. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-You got the swoop?
-Yeah. You see that? Yeah.
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
I don't even know where --
I don't know where I am on this
or where -- Like,
I don't even know where I'm at.
-Oh, how we doin'?
-'Cause I went -- Now I went to
the top of your head.
-Oh, right. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-You're just letting your eye --
Just kind of let your eye
just kind of go with the music.
There you go.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Both scatting ]
-I think I'm close as I can get
to when I'm done.
Okay, ready?
[ Both scatting ]
Alright, let me see.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's not bad.
-I'll tell you what.
-Here's mine right here.
-There we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I swear, you're much better
looking than that.
That actually
weirdly looks like me, though.
I will take that one.
-I'm laughing because you
weren't supposed to be
better than me at this.
I was supposed to be --
-What are you talking about?
That doesn't look like you.
Who is that?
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to sign it, man.
I'm going to sign it just 'cause
I don't know what
you're going to do with it.
-Now, are you going to put your
real signature on there or --
-No. I signed it
"Pete Davidson."
-Oh, of course.
-Now it's worth something.
Can we talk about "Matrix?"
-Yeah, let's talk about
"The Matrix."
Man, "The Matrix" is
so, so, so damn cool, man.
I'm excited to be
stepping back into this world.
-You're Morpheus. Well, yes.
-Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I can say it.
-Okay.
-I'm Morpheus.
-I don't want to -- Yeah,
I can't say how you're Morpheus.
-No, because they get mad when
I do say that I am Morpheus.
You know what I'm saying.
-Super-fans.
Because everybody is so loyal.
And it makes sense.
I mean, I'm loyal to
Laurence Fishburne
and, you know, to his Morpheus.
Let's give a round of applause.
-Yeah, absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Laurence Fi--
-Laurence Fishburne as Morpheus.
-But I want to take --
If you can allow me
the opportunity to say,
I'm not --
I was not hired to replace
Laurence Fishburne.
-No. No, no.
-No. I was not also hired to do
a "Laurence Fishburne as
Morpheus" impersonation.
-No, that is not --
When you see it, you'll get it.
-When the film comes out,
it will make sense.
It will be cool.
-Yeah.
-And if not, I still got paid.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no. No, no.
[ Applause ]
It is fantastic.
I was gonna ask
you, when did you, like,
realize you're in
a "Matrix" movie?
Like, did you freak out
at one point?
Did Keanu just go like, "Whoa!"
Or did he say something,
and you're like --
-It was at the table read.
The first table read.
We're in San Francisco.
We're all around the table.
And, you know,
we try to be professional
and things like that,
'cause, you know, you're actors.
You don't want to -- You know,
you're in "The Matrix."
-Yeah. You can't be a fan.
-And Keanu says -- He says,
"I still know kung fu."
And, you know, it was just like,
"Oh, my God!
I'm in 'The Matrix'!"
-"I'm in 'The Matrix'!"
-Oh, my gosh!
-You know what I'm saying?
But it's cool. It's exciting.
-If you're a fan, it pays off.
It has so many cool things
and cool story lines.
I don't even know how
they even wrote the script.
-Yeah.
-It's brilliant.
-They're brilliant.
-Alright, I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here is Yahya Abdul-Mateen II in
"The Matrix Resurrections."
Take a look.
-Oh.
No. No, no, no, no.
-Whoa, whoa, whoa!
What do you mean no?
You wanted this. You did this.
This was your idea.
-Yeah, yeah.
It was a test.
An experiment.
-An experiment?
-Yeah.
-You put me in a tiny...
left me to bang my head till I
nearly lost my [bleep]
searching for you
as an experiment?
-The exit is breaking down.
-He hasn't taken the pill.
-What? There is no time.
-I know. I know.
He's -- he's having a moment.
-Does he know how hard it was
to hack that mirror?
-It's still open.
-This -- this...
can't be real.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yahya Abdul-Mateen II.